le sourire du vainqueur
c'était en 1979 robert mugabe venait de
signer la déclaration d'indépendance du
nouveau zimbabwe après avoir combattu et
renverser le régime raciste et violent
de la rhodésie britannique il tendra la
main à ses anciens bourreaux mais sera
sans merci pour ses adversaires
politiques
les escadrons de la mort sème la terreur
ce qui lui permet de garder le pouvoir
pendant 37 ans malgré les désillusions
robert mugabe avait hérité d'un des pays
les plus développés de l'afrique avec
une agriculture moderne
il ajoute à cela un vaste réseau
d'écoles publiques et des soins de santé
gratuits mais les violences politiques
font fuir les investisseurs au début des
années 2000 pour relancer sa popularité
il plonge le pays dans une réforme
agraire dévastatrice les fermiers blancs
sont chassés de leur ferme parfois
violemment et les employés noirs son
congé dit le pays est privé de son
expertise agricole les terres sont
donnés à des amis du pouvoir qui souvent
ne connaissent rien à l'agriculture
l'économie du pays s'effondre le
zimbabwe doit abandonner sa monnaie
les écoles et les hôpitaux manquent de
tout le choléra et le sida nier par
mugabe font des milliers de morts
une autre façon et l'autre saveurs du
grand soir 10 mai jean hayden finissait
papy wade centre applications favorites
am j'ai perdu six têtes d'autres mba
bouyer lui rendent hommage
les plaies il a joué un rôle crucial
dans la guerre de libération
il a donné du pouvoir et une voix ou
noir il nous a donné le courage de nous
tenir debout
c'était unique on dit il
légendes africaines sa seule erreur fut
de s'accrocher au pouvoir trop longtemps
mugabe a encore voulu prolonger son
règne en 2017
en tentant d'imposer sa femme à la
présidence ce fut une fois de trop
l'armée l'a chassé du pouvoir tout en
lui permettant de finir ses jours en
homme libre ici sophie langlois radio
canada n'ont rien
[Musique]